This pandemic has highlighted how essential
and heroic our frontline workers really are.
And we can't thank them enough
but we wanted to do something special for one of them.
She's a single mom, which is already a full-time job.
And as well she's a nurse,
she's been selflessly braving it
to work every single day
to be there for her patients.
Please meet nurse Kate.
(upbeat music)
Hi, thanks for joining us.
I wanted you to meet my boss too,
to tell us both a little bit about your story,
if hat's okay.
Yeah, sure.
Okay cool.
I think they're there.
Oh, here she is.
Hi Kate, how are you?
(Kate gasps)
My God.
Am so good.
Thank you for talking to me.
So my pleasure.
I am really excited.
You're excited, I am thrilled.
I'm so happy to meet a nurse
who takes care of people
and a mom to a 21 year old son.
And you're living
in your first big house
that you own and you so deserve it.
Thank you.
Well, how does it feel
to have this gorgeous home that you own?
It is amazing.
I just feel that, you know, you have children.
I always put my son first and he's 21 now
and now I'm like, let's do me.
I just feel very accomplished and excited.
And it's a really great feeling.
I feel like all the hard work
and all the struggles I've had throughout the years,
finally, like paid off
you know, getting somewhere that I want it to be.
I commend you for all of that sacrifices
and everything that you did.
And I wanna celebrate where you're at right now.
Thank you.
Kate, how do you feel about
if I help you design your living room?
I would be so excited, dream come true.
Before I get started,
also really wanna ask you a quick couple of questions,
'cause I wanna be your partner in this.
Okay, is there anything that you absolutely hate?
That's a good question.
There's really nothing that I'm opposed to.
Got it.
What is your favorite color?
My favorite color,
I like blues.
Great, blues.
Great, greens are good too.
I love greens.
Would you ever dare to go dark?
I would definitely go dark.
I do have two windows in the living room,
the front one is quite large.
Is there a time in design
that you love or you're just like
yeah, I could never rock that style.
Well, I have to be honest if your styling
and I think I'd be able to rock anything
(Kate laughing)
I'm so glad.
Have you been watching, like what we do on the show
or have you seen the Flower Home?
I love the Flower Home, yes.
These designs are so adorable and great.
And like, I wouldn't even know how
to mix and match
but I love them all.
Am so honored to do this with you
and at this moment and time
and this celebratory chapter,
thank you for having me to your party.
Thank you.
Right Kate, here we go.
Let's do this.
(audience cheering)
After surprising Kate,
the team and I went to work,
compiling the right colors,
furniture, accessory and style,
to give her a living space
where she can kick her feet up
and relax after her long important days.
(upbeat music)